I don't know if you all heard the news
about Penthouse magazine the company
that owns Penthouse magazine filed for
bankruptcy yeah and yeah I and his
magazines been around forever and II III
didn't wasn't sure if I should mention
this or not but didn't you have stock in
the penthouse company yeah it's kind of
a bummer for me and I I actually just
got the letter from the CEO about the
whole deal you've got a letter from the
CEO penthouse what does it say well it's
kind of in like technical stock stuff
but I don't know it's it's interesting
at least let me check it out read it for
you dear penthouse investor I never
thought this would happen to us last
night we were working late when our
chief financial officer approached us
with his staff and said check this out
in his hand was a seven-inch thick
spread sheet that exposed all the gaping
financial holes and our once proud firm
we took a real pounding in the last
quarter he said in a low husky voice and
we'll be slammed even harder this time
if we don't put our assets on the street
right now I was worried about a
premature liquidation he said premature
we should have pulled out months ago my
knees buckled as I imagined our stock
plunging further downward and gallons of
red ink coating our bottom line so we
quit sincerely penthouse publication Wow
[Applause]
right
not like 60 bucks